I had a myopsy at a dermatologist, a lesion above my brow. Recommendation is to do
freezing, the tissue around the area, since the pathogen came back pre-cancer. Does it
so look a good idea? I have not done well with the other two biopsies on a leg, not cancerous
and freezing, of a liver abroad spot slowly healing. Um, does this sound like a good idea?
Well, you're talking to somebody who doesn't like doctors, okay? So, when I do that, no. Does that
mean you should not do that? No, it doesn't mean that you shouldn't do it. Um, the negatives
about removing skin lesions, so that there's negatives. So if I have a skin lesion that looks like
it could be a melanoma, should I get a biopsy to get a diagnosis and have them do surgical
procedure to remove it? That's typically called mose surgery. Um, if I have to give you the right
medical answer, the right medical answer is yes, you should do that. If I have to give you the
alternative, my opinion, this is just solely my opinion, I would never surgically remove what I
think could be a melanoma. Is there any harm in removing what is obviously a basal cell? No, it's
never rare, very rarely going to become malignant. You could remove a basal cell cancer. How about
another cancer that's, and you could easily google what a basal cell cancer looks like, they look
very different than a squabous cell cancer or a melanoma. So it's very easy, or even an untrained
eye to know what a basal cell cancer is. Should I remove a lesion on my skin that looks like it could be
a cancerous lesion? Definitely isn't basal cell, but it could be melanoma or it could be squabous cell.
Personally, I don't think so. The danger of cutting into it and doing that could spread it all over.
Now I know there's a million examples of people that had a melanoma removed and they never had any
problems with it, but there's also a million people that have had a melanoma removed and it's
spread it all over and they have a melanoma that is gone as a metastasized. So that's an extremely
difficult cancer to treat. What else are you going to do? There's other things a person could do. You
could use different surface-applied treatments that are natural, from essential oils to a curcumin
cream to a black sap to all these different things, but you have to be mentally prepared and there's
some work involved with it. So if you don't want to be responsible, I just want the doctor to take
this off and get this out of here and get this rid of me and I want to get it out of there, then biolamides
go and do that. If you, if that's just your temperament, everybody's different human being
and as a believer, you need to be praying about these decisions. Maybe it's the right thing to do,
it's the best thing to do and it's the absolute right thing to do for you. So I'm not against
medical care. I'm just personally, you just ask me, my opinion, what I do, I don't know that I would do
that, but that doesn't mean that it's wrong for you, especially given your history of not healing
for these things. And I don't, that's just why I'm hitting it, but you don't, I don't want to
negate what you maybe are called to do.